right now we're talking about the
anniversary effect or the anniversary
reaction and so many folks here in our
community are still dealing with this
the vegas strong resiliency center says
the impact of something as heinous as
the mass shooting here has a ripple
effect
and many folks are still coming to terms
with it
i always told myself i'm fine i can
handle this nadine luss muller is a
warrior i remember i was in the back of
a pickup truck and people were telling
me
stay with me stay with me
what stayed with her emotions that she
says she tried to cloak by volunteering
and meeting with other survivors it
wasn't until the pandemic forced
isolation that she found the help she
needed it takes time
it takes a lot of time and that's a
point she and the vegas strong
resiliency center want to get across
there's no timetable for healing and not
everyone is ready to accept that help i
actually met someone from columbine who
said
it took her 21 years
to reach out
and get help terry keener is the
behavioral health coordinator for the
center we do a lot of outreach advocacy
just trying to let people know we're
here here the center is fully outfitted
with a variety of options to help people
but out of necessity they had to switch
to virtual assistance this last year in
doing so keener says they've been able
to reach more people across the country
we keep discovering groups of people
that are impacted
it shows up in some way different for
everybody and the healing process looks
different for everyone too
nadine took the boots she wore that
night and burned them got a tattoo to
cover some of the scars on her leg and
found her purpose and happiness again
this year is the first year of where i
can say
i'm not devastated by it
such a strong woman nadine by the way
has decided to go back to school to
become a therapist to give back she says
what she's already received the vegas
strong resiliency center they are asking
anyone with anything that they may need
help with or assistance please reach out
to them that's where the healing process
begins now the resiliency center by the
way is going to have some extended hours
today for 1 october most of that is
virtually if you'd like to go in person
you do need to call ahead of time
they're going to be available today from
10 am to 8 pm and tomorrow from 10 to 2.
you can reach out by calling that number
on your screen or visiting their website